on your marks get set
bear crawl
the movement of the future is here and
it looks a lot like the movement of the
distant past
what benefits would you get from moving
on all fours
how would our society adapt to
accommodate this new movement
[Music]
and
how could it change human evolution
forever
this is what if and here's what would
happen if humans walked on all fours
it's been at least six million years
since humans started walking upright
exactly when this happened and why
is still up for debate we have no
response
but
bipedalism or moving with two rear limbs
could be a critical reason humans
evolved into the planet's most dominant
species
when the african climate began to change
your ancestors had to adapt to living in
the grasslands
and that's when they may have started to
stand upright
it was easier to see over the tall grass
this could be how natural selection led
you to walk around with that starbucks
cup in your hand
having our hands free to craft and use
tools might have been a key to creating
early civilizations
but what if we devolved a little
if you want to start preparing for a
world of quadrupedal movement you might
find some benefits
for starters you'd be improving your
balance and range of activity
it would help you develop cat-like
reflexes you could move between
positions like crouching and standing
with remarkable agility
if you're feeling sore already
good this form of movement would be a
full body workout
you'd be developing more muscular
shoulders and triceps
so
get ready to pump up your diet
many martial artists and parkour
athletes are already introducing this
into their lives
tokyo's monkey man kenichi ito can run
like a horse
this is called a transverse gala
ito set the record for the fastest 100
meters on all fours at
15.71 seconds
compare that to usain bolt who holds the
bipedal record at 9.58 seconds
but if everyone started running on all
fours it would be difficult for society
to adjust
you'd no longer be able to use your
hands to carry things with ease
yeah no more coffee on the go
no more cell phones or umbrellas and
going to the grocery store would take
several trips
also fashion would change significantly
purses and high heels would be unusable
whole new industries would emerge to
come up with intelligent solutions to
this lifestyle
oh and watch your head because anything
higher than one meter would be difficult
to see
head trauma could become commonplace
you'd want to invest in a good helmet
get ready to wash your hands more than
you did during the pandemic
being so close to the ground means
touching the soil and potential
pathogens you'd be getting sick more
often
and reorienting your body would also
lead to gastrointestinal issues
at least until our bodies began to adapt
eventually your four-legged descendants
would look more and more like your
ancestors
scientists know from fossils that as
humans began to walk upright many
changes occurred to our bodies
the shape of our pelvis changed from
tall and flat to shorter and more bowl
like
our spines curved into an s shape to
bring our body weight over the hips and
cushion the brain while walking
so what if you went back to the ways of
your ancestors
well at first this would lead to a lot
of aches and pains you'd have wrists
shoulder and hip injuries
your body just isn't prepared for life
on all fours
now on the bright side you could bid
farewell to back pain
currently this is the largest
contributor to disability in the world
most of this is due to occupational
injuries or inactivity but our walking
upright is also to blame
we transitioned from four to two legs at
a fast rate and that didn't allow our
musculoskeletan system to adapt
so once you've figured out the smoothest
most efficient way to move on all fours
you could be on your way to a body
that's able to change directions quickly
and react more instinctively
eventually your four-legged descendants
would adapt to look more and more like
your ancestors
now while you're back to walking like a
monkey i wonder what would happen if
monkeys took over the world
well
that's a story
for another
what if